the haunting of Sharon Tate was written
and directed by Daniel furans and stars
Hilary Duff as Sharon Tate and tells the
quote/unquote inspired by true events
story of Sharon Tate who's pregnant with
director of Roman Polanski's baby in
1969 and her and some friends are
attacked by Charles Manson's cult
buddies as most people know this was a
true life story Sharon Tate was murdered
and Charles Manson and his cult was
responsible
this film however takes a supernatural
look at things and has Sharon Tate
plagued with visions nightmares a lot of
nightmares look if this is not the worst
movie of 2019 we are cursed as a people
we are done we're no longer worthy of
this planet the haunting of Sharon Tate
represents the absolute worst that
horror has to offer
this is bottom-of-the-barrel
entertainment a film based off of
something that really happened to
exploit a tragedy we've seen that before
in horror
there's tons of AM knieval movies for
instance I mean this is something that's
it's not entirely uncommon what's so
weird about the film is how gross it
feels it's even a little bit repulsive
because it takes something that happened
and tries to to give it like this odd
supernatural twist to it and it has very
little to add to the actual event it's
this really stretched out film that
feels like it should have been a 20
minute short film like a concept or an
idea like a pitch to a studio but they
stretch this motherfucker out to 90
minutes by having the most elongated
scenes of Sharon Tate just walking
around a pool lounging around a pool
walking through Hollywood Hills talking
about how she feels weird or uneasy
having her friends say oh you're just
silly and what are you doing there's
random people delivering packages to us
that say they're from somebody named
Charlie and we're getting weird tape
recordings but we're not doing anything
or calling the police
which leads me to the dialogue for the
haunting of Sharon Tate
it's not even first draft I mean it is
like someone scribbled it out really
fast and just said that's good enough
there's all these pseudo-intellectual
scene
they talk about fate and death that
build to nothing you can tell there were
reshoots at least it feels like it was
like they added this the scene where
Sharon Tate is being interviewed it's
black and white and there's narration
and voiceover because of this that
sometimes appears in the movie based off
of that interview and it just feels like
an attempt to elongate things there are
weird parts where they include actual
footage of Roman Polanski and Sharon
Tate and actual cult members being
interviewed almost like it's a
documentary all of a sudden there's no
part in the film that sets that up it's
not an earned edit because we're seeing
Hilary Duff portray Sharon Tate we're
not seeing the real-life Sharon Tate but
throughout the film we randomly will see
stock footage of Sharon Tate it's
atrocious
I mentioned that she has a lot of
nightmares there are so many dream
sequences in the film where something
scary happens and she wakes up in bed
crying this happens multiple times it
was annoying the first time it was
annoying the second time this has been
the most annoying film cliche and trope
forever for decades literally decades
okay why is this in a movie still
constantly it's like they could tell
they had nothing to do they were trying
to follow that rule of 10 I think where
with a horror film every 10 pages
something scary should happen or
something interesting or something
investing so since we just have people
in a house and they're kind of lounging
around for 90 minutes I guess we'll just
have her have a lot of nightmares about
murder and death because that makes
sense right but there really is no
excuse for this dialogue one of the bad
guys actually looks at somebody and goes
well well well might as well just like
sprouted a giant moustache
instantaneously I mean there's a scene
where they're talking about fate which
is as far as this movie is concerned the
one theme that they ran with was can you
control your fate and this guy talks to
Sharon Tate and he's like I guess in
movies speak it's like we can rewrite
our own scripts I laughed so hard it was
great I also said to myself so the
writer knows you can rewrite your
scripts like he knows that's a thing you
can do now I want to get something out
of the way that I
don't really like to do and that's harp
on actors I know how hard it is to work
on a film especially from an actor
perspective you're it's all on you you
know and Hilary Duff she's not very good
in the movie to be honest and into her
defense she has nothing to work with she
is crying or having a nightmare for like
90 minutes and that's it there's there's
very little to her character on the page
and to be completely honest she's
actually a little bit better than the
script warrants but many people will
point her out as the worst part of this
film because it's easy to point out the
celebrity especially if they come from
like a Disney Channel background like
she does and say well she's the reason
this movie sucks she's not it's the
script and the director because he's
doing both of those things really though
all of the acting is pretty mediocre the
film has not one single strong suit at
all let's talk about that director for a
second in regards to directing he's well
known for some really good documentaries
that explore horror films like never
sleep again the Elm Street legacy scream
the inside story or Crystal Lake
memories the complete history of Friday
the 13th
but in 2018 he had his narrative feature
film debut with the am knieval murders
another film about just that he wrote
and directed that as well
I didn't see it I didn't hear was very
good but I didn't watch it now he's got
the haunting of Sharon Tate
another film that explores a real-life
event so I became curious about what he
might be working on next according to
his IMDB his next project is the murder
of Nicole Brown Simpson it's listed as a
thriller and it's in post-production
he's already shot it yet another film
about a real-life tragedy exploring the
murder of someone I mean he's just
cranking him out at this point and the
fact that he comes from a documentary
background does make me feel like that's
why he inserted real imagery of Sharon
Tate throughout this film like he was
used to just cutting in that type of
stuff even though it doesn't make any
sense but just the fact that that will
be the third film in a row 2018-2019 and
the third one's already done and they're
all about real-life murders it just
makes me feel gross like
that's just create your own story man
like stop looking at the news just make
up your own original story if you really
want to make horror don't just look at
real-life tragedies and try to exploit
them and you don't want to be known for
that either if he makes a third film
like that that's gonna be his thing now
let's talk about the ending no spoilers
if you really want to see this movie for
some reason and of course if you know
the real life story you probably have an
idea of what's going to happen but the
film tries to portray it in an
interesting way I guess I'll say that
and my mouth was dropped for like ten
straight minutes and in the worst way I
got chills when the end credits started
because it was so atrocious there's like
four minutes of slow motion and you can
tell that they shot it without using the
proper frame rate and so the slow motion
looks choppy it looks like something I
did when I was like 15 years old with my
shitty mini DV camcorder that my mom
gave me when I was a kid I'm not
exaggerating this is genuinely one of
the worst horror films I've seen in
years if you want to get together with
some friends and drink a little bit that
could be really fun I'm gonna give the
haunting of Sharon Tate and F like I
said if this is not the worst film
released this year we are in first shit
like we deserve to survive as a people
if this is not the worst film released
in 2019 well guys thank you so much as
always for watching look forward to more
reviews very soon and if you like this
you can click right here and get
stubborn eyes
[Music]